辞出有多快
就得看你踩多少油门
而股市上最为大众化的油门就是OBV
油门踩的
股价踩回去
市场中有这么一句话
新手看价
老手看量
能量就是原因
股价才是结果
这就是所谓的量在价限
不知道你是否使用过OBV指标
不停的研究还是不能从中收益
而且不懂你是不是有遇到这样的现象
当股价继续上涨
倒到某个高位时出现反复震荡
当你还以为会继续上涨时
股价立刻出现断崖式的暴跌
让你输得金价荡产
以我的经验的感受
其实这些主标都存在着本质的盲点
当然OBV也不例外
在还没有了解它的树心
就简单的使用OBV进出场
大部分的时候都不大好受
而这次的影片就是要讲解它存在这个世界上的真正意义
能够终重洞察到股市中的另外一个世界
OBV中文称之为能量炒
也称之为交易量金额
或平均交易量
英文称之为on balance volume
所以简称就是obv
看名字就知道
它就是股市中的一种能量表
就好像你驾车车前面的Ubem传说表
它是在1963年6月社会干维尔所提出
时刻来到了今天
依然受到市场投资者的CI
obv非常单调
本身就是一条线
它与一般我们所了解的成交量不一样
成交量表明的是当天的成交数量
而obv就是它的特别版
相比起成交量
它更直观更直白
能够反映出的不单单是一个成交日
而是在一个时间段内的价格与成交的亲密关系
它是成交量配上价格也变成的一种趋势
一共投资者更好的预测价格未来走向
属于使用成交量动力指标之一
市场上甚至有投资者称之为动能指标之王
甚至是少走10年的玩路
就问你怕不怕
首先我们需要知道如何打开OBV
如果你使用的是Trading月的话
只需要在指标里输入OBV就会看到
如果是糊涂默默的话
在指标管里输入OBV
或者直接在量价指标里就会看到
接下来就是他的公司
如果没兴趣知道的话
可以直接加速跳到后面去
OBV与传统的成交量不一样
他的公司有如小学生的数学题
是以累计的方式计算
主要是将上一个交易日的净值交易量
加上获钱去当天的成交量
那就是当天的OBV值
如果当天的股价上涨收盘价大于前一天的收盘价就是把前一天的OBV加上今天的增交量相反如果当天的股价下跌收盘价小于前一天的收盘价
就是把昨天的OBV减去当天的增交量
如果当天的股价不涨也不跌
那当天的OBV就是昨天的OBV
是不是觉得看云了
我们做个例子
比如说指的股价第一天收盘价是10美元
当天有20200的增交量
第二天收盘价是10.15美元和3万个增交量
第三天收盘价是10.17美元和25600个证交量
而第四天的收盘价是10.13美元和32000个证交量
那OPV连续四天的走势就是这样的
第一天的OPV就是0
第二天的OPV就是3万
第三天的OPV就是55600
而第四天的OPV就是23600
过后的购置就以此类推
而就随便的这些就是OPV量
就是之前不断累积二层的数量值
当然这个可以完全无视
OBB这种另类的算法简直就是小学生数学体的公式
如果今天的股价上涨就加上去
如果下跌就减下去
这就跟K线本身就是一个一样
所以打开了K线图看
股价涨了OBB也会随着上涨
股价跌的话OBB也会随着下跌
是不是觉得那里怪怪的
没关系我们接着看下去
了解了算法公式
接下来我们聊聊OBB加市场上常见的使用方式
首先就是黄金交叉和死亡交叉
相信经常收看这个频道的你来说相当熟悉
简单来说就是使用两条均线
但出现两条线交叉就是卖出或买入的信号
OBV本身就是一条线
而另外一条隐秘的均线就需要而外开设
如果是使用推定view的话
首先进入OBV的设定
然后在start里面这里打个gogo
然后再回到去input
设定你要的参数
现场上一般所使用的是21和34
当然你还可以根据自己的习惯的周期设定
甚至在这里还能够选择SMA,EMA还是WMA
使用的方式也非常简单
当OVV上传移动平约线就是买入
如果跌破就是卖出
如果在OVV线上摇摆不定就不需要理会
就是那么简单
比如这张图
如果根据这种方式
这里到这里也能吃到45%的涨幅
你应该会发现这就是与我们所说的其他技术指标一样
都会有延迟问题的存在
需要长到的一小段落地的一一大截才会后知后觉
而且如果遇到类似这样的
这些地方只会让你不停的装满卖
如果根据交叉使用方式
就会让你崩溃收场而全商公司却非常开心所以这种方式并不是说不能用但是如果真的要使用均线更加偏向于直接使用移动平均线
参考价值更为安全
除了加上均线之外
市场上的投资者甚至会使用均线来识别主力喜欢造作
至于这个话题
坦白说
先人指路更为可靠
其实之前的先人指路制品曾经有讲解过
如果还没看过的小伙伴
建议去看看
使用OBB均线交叉时
还需要注意一些特别事项
那就是单独的交易量会大幅度飙升的可能
比如意外的收益报告
新闻炒作
或大规模机构大众交易
都可能导致指标飙升或暴跌
所以这里的交易量飙升并不代表股价整体的趋势
而且还会在OBB有着相当长的一段时间内
与均线产生巨大的偏离
如果股价遇到快速暴跌
要等到OBB出现时差财宝兽
你绝对会心脏病发
相比起交叉的使用方式
OBB还有另外一种方式更为合理
那就是背离
还是一个样
一般分别为两种
那就是看涨背离和看跌背离
如果之前看过ISI视频的话
相信对于什么是背离相当熟悉
简单来说就是股价和技术指标相反走势
因为这个股价创新高
但指标不再创新高
或股价创新离
指标不再创新离
仿佛指标总是先提前通知接下来的走势
就好像打了一场侧币之战
兵马未动,粮草先行
比如这张图
股价从底部不断往上涨
出于上涨趋势
来到这里股价和OBV双双进降的一个顶峰
虽然遭到短期下跌
随后股价再次往上冲
形成更高的顶
但是OBV并没有随着股价创新高
相比起上一个顶峰还来的更低
这位置市场成交力度开始减弱
没有力气再往上推
随后有如OBV所言
股价无力上涨快速暴跌
更至关清楚的还有这个
在这里OVV和股价双双达到了顶峰
然后股价再次往上攻
创多一个顶
但OVV却不再上升
其实在这之前
这个顶峰被打破创造出另外一个顶峰时
如果OVV跟不上脚步
形成背离的情况
这就是一种危险的信号
股价暴跌即将到来
有顶背离就会有底背离
这是2018年苹果暴跌的时候
当时股价从58美元直接暴跌至35美元
跌幅足处达到了39%
相当恐怖
在这里股价创新低但OBB不但没有创新低而且开始会学复活这就意味着股价虽然往下跌但一些机构投资基金或某位大佬开始买入散户所抛售的股票
随着交易链之家
没有人在想见卖卖掉自己手上的货
市场开始做紧压力
OPV开始推动价格上涨
想要买苹果只能开出更高的价钱
如果你对苹果亲友度中
想从中抄底
那当时的OVV就是你最好的确认指标之一
最后我们来个总结
OVV说白的其实就是称较量的进化版
它的使用方式主要有两种
一种是OVV加上均线配合使用
如果出现OVV上传均线
市场称之为黄金交叉
是买入的信号
如果OVV跌破均线
就是市场称之为的死亡交叉
则是卖出的信号
另外一种就是背离使用的方式
主要分配为顶部背离和底部背离
顶部背离则是股价创新高而OPV不再创新高
底部背离则是股价创新低而OPV不再创新低的意思
这就是所谓的量再加价
先有量再有加的意思
加价使用方式个人不大会去使用
不是说不能用只是B端相当严重
如果要用之前所说的移动平均线会是更好的选择
这一OPV更大的优势反而就是它本身的均线
能够有效的了解股价与成交量的暧昧关系
当双方一介不合的时候
一个走上一个走下
就会形成贝离的情况
就好像一对轻鱼
一个想吃麻辣火锅
另一个想吃西山汉堡王
当开始闹分歧的时候
我们就需要多加留意
随着时间的过去
总会有其中一位妥协的时候
那就是我们转天的开始
是不是开始觉得欧比比好像非常厉害
但是还是那句
每个技术指标都存在这本身的盲点
要知道
贝离的情况即是没有准确的一个时间点
可以一直背离再背离下去
甚至能够达到好几个月或半年以上
虽然OVV不是一个做买卖决策的指标
但如果是让新手确认趋势方向
那就非常的合适
再配合上其他技术指标做买卖决策
绝对是完美复杂
当然
市场上还有许多OVV的其他使用方式
或者完美的参数设定
有兴趣的小伙伴可以去看看
如果股价是一辆车
那OVV就像汽车油门
转左转右任理操作
但油们一脚下去
吃粥吃饭就看自己的造法
身仙都难救
最后别忘了点击订阅按钮
以免错过重要的资讯哦
我们下次再见 拜拜